the dceu has gone up in flames and now
it seems Warner Brothers has figured out
how to kill two films with one Rock
Dwayne Johnson spent most of the build
up to Black Adam teasing that the
hierarchy of the DC Universe was about
to change but his ambitious dreams for
the franchise have seemingly been dashed
on the heels of black Adam's poor
reception Shazam Fury of the Gods has
been met with the largely negative
reviews and poor box office takings
ironically none other than Johnson
himself could be to blame for the dceu's
recent misfortunes as he allegedly
meddled behind the scenes a report by
the rap details how Johnson pushed back
against Black Adam and Shazam crossing
paths on screen most notably he
apparently vetoed a Black Adam
post-credits scene in which Zachary
Levi's Shazam joins the Justice Society
of America the Stinger was eventually
used in Shazam Fury of the Gods but the
rap says Johnson blocked any potential
appearances from his Black Adam co-stars
this is just the latest example of
Johnson interfering with the dceu back
when the the first shazam movie was in
development Black Adam was set to have a
key role however Johnson convinced
Warner Brothers to make a standalone
Black Adam film instead feeling it would
be a disservice to his character if
Shazam featured a pair of origin stories
despite the character's close connection
to each other in the comics Shazam and
Black Adam made their big screen debuts
separate from each other while some may
have thought the two would meet in a
future installment Johnson seemingly had
other ideas he infamously strong-armed
Warner Brothers into approving a Black
Adam Cameo for Henry cavill's Superman
setting the stage for a massive fight
between those two characters
we should talk
throughout the Black Adam press tour
Johnson continuously hyped up such a
confrontation by downplaying black
Adam's strong links to Shazam Johnson
unwittingly hamstrung two comic book
franchises an argument can be made that
if he used his platform and influence to
drum up anticipation for Shazam vs Black
Adam these two properties could have had
a bright future instead of being shelved
now it looks like all of these
characters will likely be either taking
a long Hiatus or getting flushed from
the DCU altogether to make room for the
whole slate of new characters this has
got to come as a major blow to Warner
Brothers Discovery the first Shazam was
both a critical and financial success
netting a score of 90 on Rotten Tomatoes
and bringing in 366 million dollars on
its estimated budget of just 100 million
dollars meanwhile Shazam Fury of the
Gods debuted with 30.1 million dollars
domestically bringing in less than half
of its Hefty budget to complicate
matters further new Heroes like Blue
Beetle are set to join the dceu if the
Flash and Blue Beetle do well for Warner
Brothers Discovery it seems unlikely
that James Gunn and Peter Safran will
see any reason to bring back failed
characters especially with so many other
dceu Heroes already on the chopping
block although Dwayne Johnson has long
been thought to be one of the biggest
box office draws around his meddling
with the dceu may have tanked a shared
three movie franchise what that means
for his career remains to be seen
[Music]